Wow I just I didn't expect to get this I
didn't write anything there's no piece
of paper there's nothing I just Wow
this is I think I want to thank my mom
mm-hmm come on take my mom too I want to
thank my mom all thanks to God I'm a
Christian I was raised that way yep I
wanted to thank something yeah yeah you
know the universe let's thank the
universe sucks I'm gonna thank Chris and
Phil I'm gonna thank Bob Peter
Rodney Cristina how you doing I
appreciate you always giving a smile to
me after a long day of work for hours
she always made sure I had ginger ale in
the room and whatnot I want to thank my
team you know CAA
you know three six zero Bravo I want to
thank the Foreign Press the forum's but
I want to thank everybody in the room
right now
I want to thank Jake come on things for
me I want to thank Jake for being such a
great friend
LPD and the M&E and the all these other
organizations who voted that I can never
remember what they are but thank you
guys for voting yes yes the world to us
I want to thank sag-aftra
for making sure that I'm treated
properly yeah I also want to talk to
Sega after about maybe splitting up
again and having sag and having after
but that's another talk well okay well
I'm on Jake's team make sure major I
want to thank ya you know what this was
a great speech Stan Lee they all I think
Stan Lee I had the world bent yeah we
want to start with Stan start with Stan
Lee and we want to thank all the other
previous spider-man movies we're all
part of the same universe and part of
the same team yes thank you for for
thank you so much everybody
[Music]